a curve has the equation y equals the
natural log of X and passes through the
points P equals e comma 1 and Q is equal
to X natural log of X write an
expression in X that gives the slope of
the secant
P and Q so I think I'm going to need my
little scratch pad for this one right
over here so this is the same question
over again and let's just try to
visualize this curve right over here so
let me draw my let me draw my axes so
let's say this is my this is my y axis
this is my y axis and then this is my x
axis this is my x axis right over here
that's my x axis and natural log of X so
let's think about a little bit the
natural log of 0 e to what power is
equal to 0 well that's going to be 1 so
you're going to you're going to have the
point 1 0 on this so that's 1 right over
there and then the natural log of
smaller and smaller numbers as we
approach 0 is going to get more and more
negative all the way going down to
negative infinity so this curve is going
to look it's going to look something
like this just as we're it's going to
look something it's going to look
something like something like like that
something like that and we know it also
has the point e comma 1 on it so it has
the point the natural log of e so if
that's 1 see that will be about 2
that'll be about 3 so that is e right
over here roughly e right over here and
that's the point a comma 1 so that's the
point a comma 1 right over there and
I'll just mark that as P they already
gave us a label for it so that is P and
we want to find the secant line between
P and an arbitrary Q for any given X the
the Y value is going to be natural log
of X so this could be so let's say that
this is our Q right over here so let's
say that this right over here is our
actually I'll just make it easier I'll
make the Q actually want to make it
clear that it is a
I'll do it out here I'm being a little
indecisive so let's say that is our cue
right over there and that's the point X
natural log natural log of X and we want
to find the slope of the secant line
joining these two points the slope of
the secant line joining these two points
so this the slope of this line I want to
try to make it so it doesn't look
tangent so it's secant so you see it
cuts through the curve so that's the
secant line right over there to
intersects the curve at P and at Q so I
want to find the slope of that secant
line well to find the slope of the
secant line I just need to find the
change in Y and the change in X between
these two points so what's the change in
so let's be clear here this is the point
this is when X is equal to well it's
just a kind of arbitrary X and this
right over here is the point Ln X so
what is our change in X our change in X
this value right over here our change in
X is just going to be X minus E is equal
to X minus E and what is our change in Y
our change in Y is going to be Ln X is
going to be the natural log of X minus 1
minus 1 that's this distance right over
here so the slope of this line the line
that contains both of these points the
slope and I could write M for slope is
going to be our change in Y over our
change in X which is equal to Ln X minus
1 over X minus E and now we can just
input that and make sure that we got
that right so let me try to remember it
Ln X minus 1 over X minus e so let me
input that so we have the natural log of
X minus 1 over and it interprets it
interprets it nicely for us right below
so we know make sure that we know what
we're doing over x minus E and now let
us let us check our answer and we got it
right